هل ترى في قاعات المستشفى ضوءًا
في نهاية النفق حيث
يبدو أن الرئيس تعلم بصراحة تامة ،
فأنا لست هنا للحديث عن
السياسة أنا هنا للحديث عن
المرضى والحقيقة هي أن ما
نراه  في الوقت الحالي ، في غرف الطوارئ لدينا
رهيبة الأسبوع الماضي عندما ذهبت إلى العمل ،
تحدثنا عن مريض واحد أو اثنين من
بين العشرات من المرضى الآخرين الذين ربما
يكونون مصابًا بفيروس CO Veda التاجي
هذا الأسبوع في وردية أمس تقريبًا
كل مريض أخذته  كانت العناية
بالفيروس التاجي والعديد منهم
شديدًا للغاية تم وضع العديد منهم على
أنابيب التنفس العديد منهم تم تعويضهم
بسرعة كبيرة ، وهناك هواء مختلف تمامًا
هذا الأسبوع عما كان عليه الأسبوع الماضي
وبصراحة تامة ، فكر في
حقيقة أن حالتنا الأولى في مدينة نيويورك
كانت  في الأول من آذار (مارس) ، كان ذلك قبل ما يزيد قليلاً عن ثلاثة
أسابيع للاعتقاد بأننا سنكون في أي
مكان لرفع هذه
الإجراءات التقييدية بحلول عيد الفصح ، وكما تعلم ،
في غضون أسبوعين أو ثلاثة أسابيع بالنسبة لي ، يبدو أن
التفكير السحري تمامًا  ما نعرفه
هو أن هناك رياضيات ونمذجة
يمكن أن تخبرنا أن عدد الحالات
سيستمر في الارتفاع ، فنحن بالفعل
في بداية تفشي هذا المرض
ويمكنك أن تشعر أنه يمكنك الشعور
بأنه ملموس
في الخطوط الأمامية
قسم الطوارئ ومن حيث الإمدادات
هل لديك كل الإمدادات التي
قد تحتاجها لأنني لا
أستطيع إخبارك بعدد الرسائل التي تصلني من
الممرضات والأطباء والمستشفيات في جميع أنحاء
نيويورك التي تعرفها مع أمثلة محددة جدًا
لما يفعلونه  ليس لدي
إمدادات الليلة ، فإن سلسلة التوريد
ضيقة للغاية ، وهو أمر واحد أقوله للناس
هو أنه عندما كنت أعمل في غرب إفريقيا من أجل
الإيبولا ، فإن الشيء الوحيد الذي لم أقلق
بشأنه أبدًا هو امتلاك معدات الوقاية الشخصية الكافية ،
إنه شيء
زملائي في جميع أنحاء نيويورك
تشعر المدينة بالقلق في الوقت الحالي بشأن عدد
الأقنعة التي يتم إعطاؤها للناس ، وأنت تعلم
أننا حصلنا على قناع واحد لبعض الأشخاص يتم
إعطاؤهم قناع تنفس n95 وهو
الأكثر سمكًا الذي يساعد على منع حدوث ذلك.  هو فيروس
ناتج عن استنشاقه من قبل مقدم الخدمة
الذي يتم إعطاؤه واحدًا من هؤلاء في الأسبوع ولا يريدك مركز السيطرة على الأمراض
أن تكرر ذلك
ونحن نعلم أن الناس قد حصلوا على
قناع جراحي واحد
وكل شيء يفعل كل شيء في وسعهم
للحفاظ على الإمدادات  لأننا نعلم أننا ما زلنا
في بداية هذا ، وبعد
أن تصبح نيويورك نيو جيرسي ستكون نيو
مكسيكو ، هذا سيكون ماراثونًا
لسنا حتى في بداية هذا
أنت